one of the other interesting things
related to Big Tech the last couple days
is this started a few weeks ago you may
remember when the daily wire guys they
put out Matt Walsh's documentary it's
called what is a woman and it was framed
as this anti-trans diatribe and Matt
Walsh wants to stop the trans people all
it was was literally Matt Walsh
wandering around and talking to experts
and regular people and just asking to
say what a woman is and people could not
do it it's quite a good movie because of
that they've been getting a whole bunch
of strikes across their channels on
YouTube and more we've got a bit from
the daily wire right here daily wires
co-ceo Jeremy boring called out YouTube
in a Twitter thread on Sunday revealing
a series of violations leveled against
his companies shows that he cast as a
betrayal of the video platform's stated
commitment to open debate in just the
last 90 days boring said accounts
associated with the daily wire have
received 104 violations for hateful and
derogatory content mainly directed at
commentary around transgender issues
there have been more than 200 violations
in the past few months he added
penalties include Walsh being
demonetized last month Owens and Knowles
being suspended for seven days after
receiving a second strike and Peterson
Jordan Peterson getting his first strike
three strikes in 90 days and an account
gets deleted boring noted during
discussions with YouTube boring said the
video platform's policy team claims they
want to be a place where we can debate
the issue but virtually every time we
discuss it we receive these violations
yet we are on the verge of losing access
to the platform boring warrant so what's
interesting about the without getting
too under the hood on on YouTube's
policies related to all of this Brock
correct me from wrong or Connor if you
get one strike you can still live stream
or is one strike and you're out on the
live streaming
live stream for a week okay so for one
strike you can't live stream for a week
so they put you in the penalty box for a
week if you get two La two strikes
you cannot live stream at all and three
three strikes and your channel is just
blown up altogether
do you see ladies and gentlemen why I
started locals.com and why we merged
with Rumble and why I hope most of you
are watching this live stream on Rumble
right now I'm very happy to report that
well our numbers across the board have
been unbelievable like they're just
growing and growing and growing but I'm
always particularly happy when I see the
rumble numbers growing and the locals
numbers growing because that is our
future whether it is because I said tits
instead of boobs or I called Leah Thomas
a guy or just any of the things I can't
sit here and do a show that I do 99 off
the top of my head constantly being
worried about pronouns and and the rest
of the policing especially because we
know that the people doing the policing
whether it came to election engineering
questions or whether it came to the
coveted stuff and vaccines and lockdowns
and masks and now all the gender stuff
they're on the wrong side of everything
and they lie about everything Rumble if
you're a Creator out there whatever you
do you're a politics guy you're a you're
a freaking unboxer you're a gamer
whatever they will not threaten to
strike it don't break the laws of the
United States you're good to go on
Rumbles
[Music]
foreign